it's no surprise that generative AI or
geni has captured our imagination it has
opened new possibilities across all
facets of our daily lives from text and
image generation to immersive
collaboration tools and augmented search
experiences geni is the key to unlocking
further value in the Enterprise it has
the power to transform customer
experiences and employee productivity we
believe we are entering a post-training
era large language models or llms are
democratizing access to AI for
application developers developers don't
need to know how to train deep learning
models they just need to have the tools
to take advantage of llms according to
the Bureau of Labor Statistics there are
over 10 times more software developers
than data scientists that's an order of
magnitude more Innovation potential with
AI we believe that application
developers will drive the bulk of
innovation in applying generative AI to
business problems within the Enterprise
these developers will be looking for the
best ways to leverage and integrate gen
Technologies into new and existing
applications they are also best
positioned to combine the power of llms
with application data to deliver
Innovation we think of the shift as the
rise of generative engineering or geneng
just as developers integrated operations
or Ops practices into software
engineering through the devops movement
we see the geneng Revolution being led
by developers with Proficiency in gen
with the rise of genen the real value
for Enterprises comes when developers
can combine generative AI with their
proprietary data to provide accurate
domain specific experiences and because
operational databases set at the heart
of all application data they play a
critical role in how developers build
these new AI assisted user
experiences while the entire industry is
excited about the potential for
Enterprise gen it's increasingly
apparent that these new Enterprise gen
applications face a variety of
challenges that cannot be addressed by
llms alone this is because these apps
need to provide accurate and upto-date
information offer contextual and
relevant user experiences and be easy
for developers to build and operate in
this context we believe that databases
with Vector indexing support can bridge
the gap between llms and Enterprise gen
apps first databases generally can
provide the most up-to-date data for
augmenting llm prompts which helps
ground the llms for accuracy and
relevance second databases are used to
store a lot of unstructured data Vector
embeddings can encode the semantic
meaning in unstructured data like
product descriptions help desk tickets
and conversation history this allows
your application to bring relevant
unstructured data from your database to
the llm enabling immerse semantic search
and complex history based conversations
and finally all of this can be done
right inside databases which are the
trusted data stores for our customers
databases are widely used with a
thriving and mature ecosystem and offer
the kinds of business critical
reliability data protection and
performance that customers need and
expect application developers are also
very familiar with using databases with
deep support in tools such as idees
idiomatic client libraries and more now
that we have established that databases
are a core part of your gen Journey
let's talk about pess according to stack
Overflow it is the most popular database
used by almost 50% of professional
developers and PG Vector has become a
popular postgress Vector search
extension why is that because with PG
vector vector search is embedded
directly into postgress providing a
simple and familiar developer experience
it enables developers to combine Vector
search with stand standard SQL
functionality which enables powerful
design patterns and lastly PG Vector is
supported by all major Cloud providers
now we already provide the leading
postgress compatible database with alloy
DV which can run anywhere in the cloud
on premises and at the edge we asked our
customers what they needed as part of
their gen application development here
is what we heard it needs to be easy and
integrated it needs to run anywhere and
it needs to perform well for interactive
user experiences so we innovated on
behalf of our customers and created
alloy DB AI alloy DV AI provides PG
Vector compatible Vector search that is
up to 10 times faster than standard
poess when using the IVF flat index it
allows you to easily generate embeddings
from within your database and fully
integrates with vertex Ai and the open
source gen AI ecosystem and with allo DB
Omni alloy DB AI runs anywhere now let's
double click on some key features in
alloy DB AI first our PG Vector
compatible Vector search engine is
tightly integrated into alloy DB query
processing delivering up to 10 times
performance improvement over standard
postgress when using the IVF flat index
in addition we have added Vector
quantization support which enables
handling four times larger vectors
second alloid DB AI automates embedding
generation to easily transform
operational data into Vector embeddings
simplifying your gen app development
this includes an ability to
automatically generate EMB biddings
using remote models hosted by Vortex AI
that helps simplify the stack improve
latencies and reduce cost lastly allb AI
fully integrates with vertex aai and
also open-source gen tools such as Lang
chain to best support application
builders in summary alloid DB now has
everything you need to build and Run
genni apps and we will continue to
evolve allb AI
this is all in addition to the many
other benefits of alloid DB like four
times faster than standard pess for
transactional workloads and up to 100
times faster analytical queries than
standard pogress thank you for watching
and get started today with allo DB
AI